The mit Japanese program is divided into two sections, especially at the 1st and 2nd grade levels
. One is the grounder session, and the other is the
beer session.
Introduce new Drew items or patterns.
And drill sessions are for students to actually practice the patterns they learned in the grammar
class.
Grammar sessions are mostly conducted in English.  The drill session
has already become a very interactive session that is conducted only in Japanese from the first grader, that light bulb.In preparation for taking the gram, the students have carefully read the explanation of the grammar in the textbook
.
There are about 40 to 50 new words in
each lesson.
Well, I've been enrolling students to practice properly on the online x site and face drill sessions since I was
a
year
old.
It's very difficult for teachers to do it using only words, but
what we often do is to create a delivery plan with lots of visuals, and of
course, slides and various
other teaching materials.  We bring it into the classroom
and create an environment where students can learn the language in that context as much as possible.